the Australian Entertainer Barry
Humphries has died it's been confirmed
at the age of 89. best known of course
for his Persona Dame Edna everage the
Australian prime minister has tweeted
out this from the Twitter account of
Anthony Albanese he says for 89 years
Barry Humphries entertained us through a
galaxy of personas from Dame Edna to
Sandy Stone but the brightest star in
that Galaxy was always Barry a great wit
satirist writer and an absolute one of a
kind he was both gifted and a gift may
he rest in peace
just confirmation there of the death of
the Australian Entertainer comedian
Barry Humphries who has died at the age
of 89.